let's talk about how scary things can
really get we got the story from the
hill washington post issues correction
on 2020 report on tom cotton lab leak
theory
now that headline from the hill is
irresponsible in my opinion because
they did not issue a correction they
issued what's called a stealth edit
which i'm sure many may be familiar with
but let me show you this tweet from greg
price
greg is uh he's just he doesn't have a
bio but he's verified on twitter
that pro that means everything greg's uh
daily caller daily caller there you go
yeah he's great he's good
he tweets democracy dies in stealth
edits on 15 month old headlines
the first image the washington post says
tom cotton
keeps repeating a coronavirus conspiracy
theory
that was already debunked and now it
reads
tom cotton keeps repeating a coronavirus
fringe theory that scientists have
disputed so what happens is
right now it's happening across the
board on he's been upgraded from
debunked to fringe
that's right conspiracy to fringe
and dispute to disputed by science right
right
it's not the only outlet doing this
congratulations senator
these news outlets are literally
rewriting history there
think about what it used to be like in
the past 100 years ago
oh this is winston smith what what what
is this night this is the plot of 1984.
there you go that that's his job
right right in the beginning is he's the
guy who edits old newspapers
so but but in reality a hundred years
ago a newspaper would come out and it
would say
you know jack jackpot does backflip and
you'd be like there it is it's reported
and there's a photograph of jack doing
this amazing backflip you should see my
back clip
the best nowadays there'll be an article
on you know washington post website
and it'll show the backflip and then a
month later without anyone noticing
the article will be different and it'll
say jack posobik falls doing backflip
and there's and the photo is still there
but it looks a little different it's a
different photo or it's gone all
together
see back in the day a hard copy wouldn't
be changed right
they would have to issue a correction
later on if they made a mistake in the
next
paper today they don't even issue
corrections
they just change the articles now here's
where it gets crazy
wikipedia supposed to be this great
encyclopedia of the modern era right
how many articles on wikipedia use that
washington post story that says
debunked conspiracy the story is
different now
do we go and delete all those
encyclopedia entries that are now
incorrect
this is a huge problem with how we are
collecting
and disseminating information in today's
in today's era
news organizations can just change what
they said a year and a half later
and then our encyclopedias don't make
sense anymore
because what so if someone were now to
write an article
related to coven they could use this
article the same link
to make a different point they could say
it you know it was a fringe theory
scientists dispute it well as another
article says it's a debunked conspiracy
theory
so these inconsistencies will start
popping up the more they do this and to
to to piggyback what you're saying if
let's say you've been living under a
rock right for the longest time you're
just someone who's like total normie
not interested in any for whatever
reason you're not interested in covet 19
you you know but you you want to learn
about it now you say what's slap leak
theory people are talking about i want
to dig into it a little more
and they say oh cotton brought it up and
it was disputed back then but that's not
true
right so if the washington post wanted
to tell the truth they could have said
yes it was considered a conspiracy
theory when it was first talked about
however
over time it gained traction and here's
why it gained traction
and here's the actual story of it but
this is the problem because they don't
set themselves up as
i mean think about you don't have to
have a position on anything anymore
right because your position is we are
the truth and so if we are truth then
whatever truth is can become
a living target instead of it being what
uh uh what the truth is we will report
what they're saying now is what we
report is the truth is the truth right
exactly so it doesn't matter what really
happened it matters what they decide to
put on paper
and that's a problem that's a huge
problem it has been that way to an
extent for a long time
but now stealth editing has become so
widespread
and when it comes to very serious
historical moments like this
this is actually really scary you know
why
if we're not collecting information in
any other capacity
i mean i suppose we have archives we
have uh you know archive that is we have
the wayback machine what happens in 50
years
in a hundred years and they're like what
happened with covet and they look back
at all the articles
and it says lab leak was confirmed very
early on
tom cotton so so right now it says tom
cotton pushes fringe theory
great in a year i'll say tom cotton
pushes proven theory
they're going to go back and rewrite
history we knew the whole time tom was
right
so what happens in 100 years history
will be dramatically different
we witness it we witness the media lying
but future generations are going to look
back at the archives and they'll be like
they were always right
see washington post wrote tom cotton is
correct about lab league theory that's
the headline says no and they rewrite
the story
why change it why not just put like you
know the guardian does this the
thing up here says this article is three
years old right yeah i actually like
that
even though i don't like the guardian
right but i actually like that they put
that up because
even if it's it's one of things where
you know someone will
someone will do this on twitter to get
retweets sometimes um where they'll post
like an old article but they'll make it
seem as if it's breaking
and it's something yeah you know what
i'm talking about and then it starts
getting shared a lot
well and i want i don't know if guardian
was thinking about this
and the sort of the social media
interplay where people only read
headlines anymore
um because that's what's happening more
and more is that when you do click it
the first time
that it'll show hey just so you know big
blinking letters this thing
is several years old this information
could be out of date
and by the way that's okay yeah because
things change
in life right you know stories have a
beginning middle and end sometimes they
keep going sometimes you get the mcu and
there is no story
all right oh oh we got jokes folks we
got jokes
and um or you get the simpsons where it
just kind of like trails off into
like the oblivion but you know it it
allows you to sort of understand this
and
this is a plot in actually a lot of
movies where you're going through the
microfiche and you're understanding oh
so
this this happened here and then this
happened and then you're able to weave
the narrative together well
if you don't have that then how do you
figure out anything
what i really love about this media
phenomenon is that there are a lot of
organizations that will do an
aggregation of say the ap
or reuters right and so it'll just say
like yahoo news and then it'll say new
york post
i i find this all the time because yahoo
news will pick up
a lot of stuff yahoo is really weird
like that and that because they have
some
some that are that are internal but a
lot that are from somewhere else and
it'll just say new york post so what's
funny is
the new york post will put out a story
and then issue a correction and yahoo
news
will run the uncorrected the the false
version
and they both simultaneous
simultaneously exist
as certifiable credible organizations
for wikipedia's editors and newsguard
certified
so you can literally just pick which
narrative works best for you i suppose
what happens then choose your own
reality well as we know people choose
news which confirms their bias yep
so the conservatives will find the
corrected piece and go oh right there
and they'll post it on facebook
and the democrat liberals and those in
the leftists will be like oh right there
the yahoo version they'll post it
and now you have two versions of the
same story i'll tell you what though man
it really does feel like uh there's an
article written in uh am great
american greatness by um man i forgot
the guy's name
but he he writes that the democrats have
already seceded from the union
talking about the the crazy things
they're doing they don't believe in the
history of this country they don't
believe in the rule of law they've
intervened in
in the chauvin trial demanding violence
clearly they're not
working in the same capacity as we are
and i look at that number one
by the way you see chauvin he only he i
say he said i only want
you know if i want a new trial number
one but number two
i should only get probation because the
system is completely broken
yep well so this is interesting i
remember the sondelin hearing
probably the most important example of
what's happened to this country
i was uh i can't remember where the
images is from
but there's i think it was at the gym
and there's two tvs side by side
there's fox news and there's like abc
this is the first impeachment
yeah uh this was ukraine gate yeah so
well that was the first impeachment yeah
so we don't even talk about it anymore
sandlin actually was the second one
donald trump told me no quid pro quo
right
but i kind of felt like there was one so
fox news
the chiron says sandlin quote trump said
no quid pro quo right on the tv to left
of it
sandlin confirms quid pro quo
how can we function as a country when
people are like fox news is lying it's
fake news i'm like but they quoted the
guy
they quoted sandal in what he was saying
and then they're like but abc news they
they get to the truth
and then conservatives look and they're
like that's a quote if you can take one
sentence and turn it into two completely
opposite news stories
and it results in people at each other's
throats
mass conflict in the streets riots i
don't see how we come back from that
well and the problem is and it's
something that you know you've talked
about a ton
but i think we've all experienced it
where so many of these outlets have
gotten away from
hey and we're not going to be arbiters
of truth we're going to be arbiters of
narrative because we're chasing an
audience
yeah have you chasing clicks have you
seen the project verita veritas
deposition
of lauren windsor no i haven't seen that
so
i don't know the full context it's just
one of the clips i saw from from james
o'keefe
they put out talking about you know
swing the new york times and all that
right and they asked this woman
and i i may be getting this wrong so
just double check and go watch the video
but
they said something will sue us all if
we get it wrong no they know it's kind
of but but uh the the lawyer is asked uh
asks
the lawyer asks this woman why didn't
you include this video
in what you were producing and she just
like shrugs and goes
because it wasn't necessary for the
narrative we were trying to produce
and and i hear that i'm like the
narrative you are trying to produce
that's crazy thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time